so we have asdas
from turkey uh as i mentioned
at the start of the show i'm the warm-up
act today
um live on iranian doing
blindfold banter blitz at um
at six o'clock central european
so i will be finishing up
after a couple more games
um
okay we've got ourselves a
so far a three nights game
that may
that may lead to well for instance
fortnite's game or we could have had the
i think it's called at least in
norwegians it's called the prussian
attack with
knight to g5 and um
um or the italian possibly with
d3 and then
uh and then uh
bishop c5 i know there's uh
i think there's something called the
fried liver attack
i think that name is so stupid i don't i
don't recognize it and i
i'm using the norwegian prusian instead
um it's well known by the way that
in the four knights you shouldn't really
go bishop c4
since knight e4 equalizes or at least
equalizes on on the spot um
and the way that
he's played it he's probably
probably worse already with uh
um with uh
having lost the bishop pair um and
also i have a very nice looking position
on the king side here with the
ponson f5 and e5 uh potentially giving
me
attacking chances later on next
uh i will develop with bishop d7 rook to
e8
possibly even b6 bishop b7 bring the
bishop on the long diagonal knight b5 is
a very good move
um probably the best one that he had
but even though i lose the bishop pair
here i'm not that worried since i
i will have a very strong center after
taking back with
with the pawn and i do feel like
my attacking chances will will remain
b3 is also very reasonable
here uh developing the bishop either to
b3
possibly a3 after exchanging on
on um
on d6 i think i will just play it very
simply here
forcing him to to take after which i
will
strengthen my center and i will never
have to to worry about the pawn on e5
now i think the time has come to play f4
as well uh opening up a pretty
significant i think threat of
bishop to h3 and in general
just gaining gaining more space on
on on the king side king of one is a
very reasonable move
i think it would have been a better move
though um
were it not for the fact that he's
played c4 which is a good move
positionally
but tactically here this means
that um d3 will be hanging with check
which is a huge issue for my opponent
normally after bishop
f5 would he would have had knight h4
attacking both the queen and the bishop
rendering
rendering bishop f5 pretty um pretty
harmless
now however um
knight h4 would not have been possible
because i have the in-between check
on d3 followed by queen h7
uh retaining the protection of the
bishop on d3
and after d d4 i will have a very nasty
in between check
on d3 um
after which i will go e4 attacking the
knight
and it this is a huge positional
achievement for me
to get the pawn to um to e4
since this will mean that i have massive
attacking chances
later on with with f4 and
and um sorry with f3 or e3
brakes i mentioned earlier on that
the um the pawn tandem on f5
and e5 uh was very good for me
seeing as um it will give me a talking
chances and
now it's sort of um
coming to fruition already
f3 now g3 is the only way not to get
mated
and then e3 i think i'm just
breaking through with um with brute
force
should be mentioned that um okay and
this is another
typical sort of mental error that we
make we ex
okay uh i wasn't sorry dude i wasn't
sitting there just um torturing you
before i checkmate you
uh but it's you sort of automatically in
your mind when you
when you grab a piece like a rook you ex
expect um a recapture immediately
but then sometimes
you don't have to recapture and often
when you capture rook
it's with check but in this case yeah i
would have had the mate